so a lot of the wives are triggered on
this app saying I'm young inexperienced
don't know what I'm talking about but I
listen to what the men say every single
day through consultations through what I
do for work YouTube videos made about
you guys don't shoot the messenger I'm
just letting you know a lot of you are a
shitty wide sorry okay this is the wrong
one I thought it was a different one
okay my the one I'm talking about
because I was responding to the other
one I just said okay look if you don't
clean you don't cook and you don't have
sex with him what does he get out of
that
that's a shitty wife and you leave and
take half [__]
I mean you've got you've got the point
it's a basic principle of marriage
you're a shitty wife
okay if you could start if you get fat
oh God you're not loyal because you know
70 to 80 of women in the US are
overweight 78 yeah so yeah so so that's
one two we're not loyal we leave 70 to
80 of the time
on top of that
um one out of four marriages is sexless
so and I I can't imagine most women
really have their original recipes
really cater to men support them so it's
like can we really say we're doing a
good job as a girl I'm including myself
in this right but I'm just saying as a
group can we say we're we're offering a
lot
I feel like a lot of it comes down to
the fact that marriage is now
nearly a political statement it's
nothing to do with the religion aspect
of it I'm not religious myself but I
come from a very religious background
I'm I'm born and raised in Northern
Ireland very religious and all the basis
of marriage is like the core elements of
it you take religion out of that yeah
marriage is nothing but a statement yeah
she's right she's no you're right
because it's the because religion has
become you know watered down and fewer
people are religion religious today and
also societal constraints but the
societal constraints came out of
religion didn't they you know the whole
reason that it was so
um frowned upon for people to be
divorced and certainly for women to be
divorced in the past was because of the
religious aspects to it we'll take out
the religion and suddenly it's like well
what is the incentive do you know what I
mean there is no incentive and that's
that's the problem with the marriage
contract now
I also think that's quite sad because I
feel like marriage has lost its meaning
like let's not forget marriage is a
beautiful thing it's a sacred thing but
that's only that's only if you're
religious that's the issue that that is
coming up at the minute I think they
come I don't know
the marriage
don't actually get that security the
type of security that you get when
you're married doesn't get sick because
the man doesn't get the security because
70 of the women leave I would say yeah
it's with fault we don't get security
okay we wanted to work we said send us
to work and then we go to work and now
the wages are cut in half for everyone
when you got double the amount of
employees it's our own fault and then
women women who's in charge of sex right
so women said you know what I used to
require marriage to have sex with me now
we don't do that some spots our own
fault
because of women
[Music]
I'll tell you I'll tell you this my
grandma my grandma
old lady sweet lady she had nine kids my
dad had 13. my mom had I got a lot big
family right and you know she's getting
older right and I asked her
um like Grandma why do you think like
the divorce rate spiked so much because
the divorce rate really went um up in
the 60s right and I was like Grandma
like what like why is that like what
what happened you were you around right
she looks at me she says birth control
made him do it
oh wow oh okay she doesn't know [__]
about stats but if you look you look at
the birth control rate and the divorce
rate they're the same
so what are you saying that the birth
control does something to the women kind
of thing now I think women just wanted
to sleep around oh yeah lovely
um
to have a difference in your
it's just what you're attracted to at
the time when you're a hormonal yeah I
heard that I've heard stories there's
some really interesting research I'm
very scientific I I study science as a
degree some really interesting research
on it but it still doesn't give to a
reason have you heard about women who
get married to a dude when they're on
birth control and then they come off
yeah
a materialistic
is that because when she's on the birth
control she's looking for a certain type
of dude it's a completely different
hormonal imbalance in the body so when
you come off the breast control is it a
different hormones is it basically when
she's on birth control she's looking for
a more of a dad kind of character and
then she comes off it she's looking for
life it's a personal preference
you were right because I thought it was
because this isn't when you're on birth
control like the body tricks you into
thinking yeah yeah and you're looking
for those aspects like a strong man man
with good selective genes good
I thought you wanted the resources
that's the you when you feel that you're
pregnant you want that security but then
when you come off it it's just [__]
go wild in it yeah
they come off it and they're like
I don't know if you guys agree with this
or not but there's an idea in the men's
online you know advice space that
basically women look for two different
things they look for the dads and they
look for the cats so they look for the
guys who are more like the provider guys
more he's a nice guy he's Dependable
he's solid he's got a good pension
pension planning place you know all that
stuff and then you've got the sexy the
sexy dude over here who maybe hasn't got
any of that stuff but he's ripped and
he's like Devil maker and he's like does
you know he's that kind of and and
there's this idea that women look for
those two things so what it sounds like
you're saying is that all the birth
control they go for the first and then
they come with the birth control they're
like right where's Chad yeah
where's the pool boy anything these days
men wants kids more than woman wants
kids I think it's I um
I think today's society though is not
more about what the man or woman wants
it's more about what's being pushed on
you yeah so a lot of people are thinking
I don't want too many children because
the financial aspect of it or I don't
want too many children because the
environmental aspects of it or it's just
personal preference
yeah exactly and there's a huge amount
of evidence now saying if you're into
your 40s and you're having a child you
increase the risk of them having severe
other problems abnormalities having Down
syndrome and as much as those children
they thrive in life but it's not fair to
push that on them knowing you're you're
going into your 40s and you're having a
child I mean I I don't I don't agree
with it it's not fair when she was 45
not it's not everyone it's not everyone
but the science the science supports it
saying once you reach a certain point
you increase that risk of something like
that happening or still births or having
a child that has fear fatal fatal um
which then into their very very young
years end up dying so I think that's a
lot of the things that now because we
have the research back and up people are
going well it's too late and I don't
wanna I don't want to force that on a
child which is fair which is fair with
both sides man and woman I think it's
both works both ways what age is it over
for a woman
what age is it like it's you're not
gonna be a wife well it's really but it
depends about kids let's talk about okay
let me I'm just going to clarify a
little bit we're not going to talk about
the exceptions I know somebody yeah
there's always going to be acceptable
all right there's always going to be so
I heard a lady gave birth at 60. oh yeah
but nothing knowing knowing that men
today are more hesitant to get married
right and half of they're predicting
half of women in our age group aren't
even going to be married they're you
know 50 of us in the room never married
no kids that's what they're predicting
okay at what age
is it would you say over you know that
probably No One's Gonna Marry You no
one's if no one's trying if no one's
tried to marry if no one's tried to
marry you yet you're probably never
gonna get it oh what age what do you
think
um as a woman
um what age would you say when you're a
spinster like no offense
late 40s 45 late over okay kind of yeah
when do you think it's over oh yeah I'd
say probably 45 and over yes okay 45
same yeah 40. I'm gonna come back to you
45.
I think because a lot of people because
people who are getting married tend to
want families doesn't it so they're
going to look at them and go what if I
might love you but I yeah but in
traditional aspects marriages to support
a family and they might look at it and
go we're most likely not going to have a
child so I mean if I'm not religious is
there any point getting married at this
point that's why I said I didn't say
relationship marriage all right Trey
what do you think what age uh 27. 27. oh
my God
I knew that would trigger that I knew
that would trigger everyone out I just
like the precisiveness specific
um in all seriously so if we're talking
about having kids though as well like
not just are we talking marriage and
kids this is just personally I feel like
most guys over a certain age they'll get
in a long-term relationship with a girl
but why get married if there's no kids
yeah no true true so true at what age is
it would you say as a guy you're like um
couldn't start a family with her you can
have that to me but if you don't have
kids so if she if you had a girl you
really liked right and you were thinking
of someone you wanted to start a family
with but you said you know what too old
I mean to be honest I think it's going
to be like mid-30s yeah yeah
realistically because of the things
you're talking about as well because you
start to think getting much older than
that you start thinking well you know
would everything be be okay you know
um
yeah
because if you think about it what do
women's Peak fertility use really yeah
it's like 22 23 right yeah yeah yeah
just under 25 I think yeah you start
reaching 30 that's when it starts
getting quite dangerous yeah 90 of your
eggs are gone by 30. yeah wow
crazy that's why marriage used to be so
much younger that's why people used to
get married a lot younger but now now a
lot of people don't want to have
children so they get married a lot later
because it's yeah I mean you could
definitely if it's just if it's just
marriage for like companionship then to
be fair people could get married older
you know like you might meet somebody
you know in the nursing home and you're
just like all right
on the death bed oh my God
I noticed are you engaged I saw the I
see that me no I always get asked this
no this is um on the right hand not on
the left hand okay no everyone always
asks me that no not yet soon maybe
hopefully how funny we pray
um okay next question next question
because I feel like I was given so much
Flack for this are you a good wife if
you get married and then you gain 100
pounds is that good wife
I'm just I'm just asking am I off base
I mean was there a reason for that like
it's so impossible it doesn't matter the
reason I mean you're not a bad wife for
gaining a hundred pounds
so like okay let me let me just say so I
lost my job and refused to work as a
husband but I did it for a reason
am I a good husband
you know I lost my job but I was
depressed I mean I think that happened
it could be on benefits yeah I didn't
say I didn't say yeah it doesn't happen
I didn't say you couldn't work through
it I just said good good means like a
student good A B student right that's
good um I don't know I kind of need
specifics because like gaining weight
and being depressed
obviously man you can gain weight as a
girl because you're depressed okay
so so you know I got married I'm in love
Krispy Kremes every day if if you're not
willing to look out for your own health
though yeah yeah
no I don't I don't think it is so my
question good wife or bad wife
see I don't think it's I don't think
it's quite a straightforward but in it
I have a question to pick one you gotta
pick good or bad I have a question I
would say if I'm still looking after him
and doing all the things that a wife
should do but yeah I just gained a few
pounds or whatever I said 100. yeah well
still looking after him he can't say
nothing I'm still a good wife
all right I'm gonna get the same person
like does it change does it look at
Piers Brosnan is that his name who's
that his wife the old James Bond his
wife was stunning when they were young
and now if you look at her she's gained
a lot of weight and he told them he was
like I didn't fall in love with her
because of the way she looked he was
like I fell in love with her salt yeah
yeah I think that sounds like I don't
know why men cap he would not have
approached her come on
they sell us this fairy tale you know
I'm not saying that she can't provide
other things but that action all right
can we just start that action is that a
good wife
I didn't talk about her cooking
as well like if you don't care and
there's no backline issue to why you've
done that no it's a bad way yeah it's a
because if you don't care and you've
gone you should love me the way I am if
that's how it was in the beginning then
that's why maybe I'm coming across a bit
strong but she said she was oh she was
real who said they're real she's the
realist so far
okay okay next one on my list all right
if you refuse to have sex with your
husband good wife or bad wife bad okay
thank you thank you good night for bad
refuse yeah
I need contacts yeah like I have no idea
what that means I think in a
stereotypical sense because normally
when a woman refuses is because there's
an emotional disconnect or there's
something that's seriously going wrong
then should you still be married then or
should you got married no but I mean
I have a question do good wives put
their feelings above what's best for the
family
yeah oh it's me well I don't I don't
feel right so let me just not sleep with
my husband because of the way I feel is
that a good wife my feelings before
everybody else's I mean as long as
you've expressed that to your partner
and he's okay with that no I don't have
to be open I just wanna I just don't
have a question I'm just just yeah
are you guys okay oh with with having do
you think most men would be okay with
having a wife that does not have sex
with them no no okay no I think it would
be a problem okay yeah it won't be
problematic okay because you guys were
like well maybe if I explain to him why
I'm not is there a reason they could
give you you're like you know what I'm
super happy to just not have sex I think
that would be robbing salt into the
wound to be honest I think that might
make it worse if she's trying to justify
it it's like because the problem is what
the guy's giving you is his commitment
he's giving you his commitment I'm not
gonna sleep with anyone else and then
he's and then if you're also not having
sex with him then obvious obviously
that's going to leave him in a deficit
but there's obviously a reason for it
but it depends yeah it really has to
depend what that reads for example if
she's with like an abusive man that's a
completely that's one of those
extremities
why do we keep going to the extreme when
we're talking about the norm
I think she's looking at stereotypes
the intimacy if there is a problem
I say that because women use it
sometimes as a weapon we do yeah yeah
and I don't think that's okay yeah
that's not okay but she's probably using
it as a weapon because there is a valid
reason but could she be not wanting to
be intimate with him because just
because the butterflies are gone just
because she's like no see that's wrong
sure yeah but that that means like
something really like Oh you mean it's
wrong she does that but why do you guys
okay yeah why do we keep adding things
to avoid the actual question is not
sleeping if you're a good
if you refuse to sleep with your husband
that is the question it's not if you're
an abusive
it's just are you a good wife if you
won't have sex with your husband without
the extremities I think is what she's
trying to say okay that's so confusing
to me because I'm trying to put my mind
I'll tell you so I'm a friend he's a
20-year divorce attorney he says it's
very common that women get the two kids
they want and they just stop sleeping
with the husband they got what they want
okay no that's wrong
and a lot of times it's not for a really
good reason if women we have Stu like it
depends where we are in our cycle we're
crazy
I'm mad at your boyfriend for something
stupid yes
every day you don't think good wives
know that you know we can be crazy we
can be emotional so we put the family
before us feelings
yeah yeah yeah anyone disagree with that
no okay
okay so good wives have sex even when
they don't want to yes or no I think
that's a connection
yeah yeah
sure yes
yes she doesn't she's fighting it
it's hard because I don't agree with it
so yeah I'll say yeah yeah whatever you
guys are saying
yeah but I I it depends on what kind of
of time of frame like time frame that
you're talking about if you just mean in
general yeah
there should even if you're not feeling
totally up to it but you haven't had it
in a while it's a respect thing yeah
you're married to them give like I would
want the same from them so yeah back and
forth in it but if there was some
underlying I know
Irish want to leave at a London
but yeah yeah I think if if it's uh just
you know it's a back and forth in it
like you have to
literally I have another question okay
how many meals if we're talking a
student the best wives how many meals
should a good wife cook for her husband
a day
a good a student
no how many
one no that's an A okay what about you
one one that's an a student okay I'm
gonna say two that's okay that's an A A
okay how am I how Mills yeah how many
meals there's three minutes luncheon
didn't I yeah how many meals and snacks
[Laughter]
first
sometimes
um
uh I'm gonna say one and a half like
you do the prep who does the coke yeah
all right what about you
um I quite like cooking so I do three
three Good Wife okay don't what would
you say that a good husband pays a
hundred percent of the bills a plus
husband
no no a plus like like this is the the
ideal like again we're always I'm
talking I do ideal
I don't think you should pay for
everything okay I think his money is our
money my money is my money
high five oh no I'm sorry I finally do
it that's weird Okay do good wives look
at their money as the family money or is
their own money
the a plus wives family family yeah
like you don't think that's a selfish
mentality that is yeah it is
oh my God yeah so like um if my husband
has money and I have money like it's for
the family okay basically if I've
answered and you you high-fived her why
why
um
because I kind of agree with that like
yeah like my money is my money
he knows that I can do what I want with
that obviously because I'm a good wife I
am going to invest that into yeah I'm
gonna I'm not gonna spend it I'm
probably gonna invest it in my kids I'll
maybe have like 20 for me to go get my
hairs done
for my man you know of course
in return he gets one meal a day
he gets one meal a day all right he gets
two he gets lunch and dinner but
breakfast is off the cards I wake up
late
so would you spoil your mum would you
spoil your mum yeah because you said
that your money's your own so would you
just spend on yourself or you would you
no I'm gonna spoil my mind what do you
mean like specials
you see something that he really likes
you're like you know what I'm gonna get
this woman yeah yeah with mine are you
gonna are you gonna buy him let's say
what's an expensive watch
listen no honestly if I'm making that
type of money I will buy him his
favorite one yeah okay now another
question do good wives give up their
careers for their children
I think yes yes
yes
she doesn't like it definitely yes no I
don't I'm talking a plot remember this
is I'm not saying everyone's got to be
an a student in everything no no I don't
give up your careers no oh good good
wives should go to work instead of spend
time with their kids no for a certain
amount of time yeah you know I get it
you know staying home with your kid but
definitely going back I believe I mean
so I'm talking about when push comes to
shut your kids need you yeah so if
you're gonna have children they should
always come first regardless whether a
man or a woman I mean yeah yeah okay
this is this is the problem with Society
at the minute this is the problem with
Society now no but it is that they have
children and they focus on Career if you
want to have a child
whether you're a man or a woman you have
your sacrifice
so many children are emotionally
neglected because they're passed off to
to nannies or their pass off to Au pairs
yeah and if you're willing to have a
child you need to have a financial
support to be able to go I'm going to
take a step back I'm not going to quit
work you don't have to quit it just take
a step back to be able to go this child
needs me emotionally for the next 17
years of its life you know what I mean
Rich
the gestation period of humans is much
longer good good wives are happy to give
up their careers to spend more time with
their children yes okay yeah okay yeah
you agree yes yeah okay why aren't you
like I'm just curious like why why
wouldn't you want to give up your career
for a kid I mean of course I would like
in the beginning that growing up I have
to be there
um but I don't believe in like
completely cutting off your career just
because of your kid of course you love
your child that is that's you you gave
birth to that child I understand that
but completely neglecting your career
something that you've like worked for
maybe you've gone to University
um you know you've you're driven in this
you love it and you've given it up I
just don't believe in that why
and you wanted this family right yeah
most the time you can come back to it
though yeah but not for 17 years I'm not
going to take a break no no no I never
say it I never say just drop the careers
you shouldn't you don't think good wives
would want to like good wives if they
could take 17 18 years off to raise the
kids what's so good about I mean a lot
of jobs anyway to be honest I mean
what's so good about like we're the only
species on the planet that work and pay
to live on the earth if you're going to
raise something that's so natural you
should be willing to drop some of that
materialistic aspect if you have the
support surrounding it but I think it
works both for a man and a woman I don't
think you should if if you're a single
dad you should and you have the
financial support there you should
definitely want to spend more time with
your child and maybe put your career as
a second second best yeah I mean surely
what is the ultimate purpose that we're
on this planet it's it's other people
isn't it it's children it's fat it's
family it's all of those things right I
mean so so why is any of us why is any
of us men or women why are we saying oh
just go and work at a cubicle is more
important than that as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible